floor lamp a cubes there how away in God
my Pacha one because it's for
hey everyone my name is Matt bellezza
and this is whine about it a weekly
video series where I get drunk at my
desk and complain about stuff on this
week's episode reasons why fall is the
worst even though I know it's your
favorite season you all jizz your pants
for a venti pumpkin spice latte with
extra can whip cream they guess what
fall blows a little bit it's all time we
just admitted that to ourselves and got
on with our lives
let's drink cider apple cider I think I
need to add some rum the people drink
cider and run that's a foul drink
it's a quadrant
oh that was a bad decision but we have
to live with it alright first of all
let's just get this out of the way
pumpkin is a [ __ ] flavor punku is a
flavor
there's manufactured by Starbucks to
make people and furry ugg boots [ __ ]
their yoga pants
you know pumpkin is a vegetable that
thing that you're all blowing your leafy
loads over is damn vegetable juice with
a little bit of a whip spit on top of it
squash well it's a squash all I know is
pumpkin tastes like if you put cinnamon
on a sandcastle
pumpkin is just like nature's genital
wart okay we all we all deal with it we
all deal with them next everybody's just
insufferable during fall oh you want to
go watch the trees change color that's
what they say you want to go look at all
the colorful foliage foliage so that's
what I say you want to go sit by the
fire and grip a bug with two hands and
talk about maple trees and squash
patches and grind it in the back of a
tractor with hay driven by a guy in a
flannel shirt named burrow in enough why
don't you and your chunky Ralph Lauren
scarf go jump it to a lake good jump
into a lake that's what I say next
squirrels
okay the squirrels are angriest in the
fall than they are at any other time of
the year it's all I care about is
getting their berries in their acorns
and their pastries
yes they do squirrels love pastries as a
matter of fact November 17 2012 I baked
myself a tray of delicious warm soft
Pillsbury sugar cookies baked them all
by myself I'd Ted they set them down on
the table to cool off and come back an
hour later and what do I see a massacre
crumbs everywhere all over the floor all
over the table all over the ground my
cookies were Exhibit B this [ __ ]
sitting outside my window peeping in
with his [ __ ] beady little eyes
he knows he knows what he is doing not
believing me yet you believe with this
squirrel did it Exhibit C one week later
who do I find right outside my window
again with another pastry that he stole
from someone else's kitchen he brought
it back right to my windowsill just to
taunt me just to throw it in my face you
think his summer squirrel would behave
like this you think a spring squirrel
would break into my apartment and steal
my homemade sugar cookies no it's a fall
squirrel sort of [ __ ] monsters next
everyone wants to know apple picking
why why you want me to pay $40 to drive
to a an orchard to pick wormy apples off
the ground the only way you'll take me
apple picking is if you take my [ __ ]
corpse you might as well carry around my
corpse we're to be carrying around a
damn bushel of apples also while we're
on the subject of apples apple pie is
disgusting someone needs to say it I
don't give a [ __ ] if you think apple pie
is delicious it's much a hot goopy slimy
apple slices that you just jammed into a
dusty ass crust and then everyone's like
oh it's American that's why you have to
like it you know it's a better pie than
apple pie any [ __ ] pie any other pie
is better than apple pie then finally
everything is moist and muddy and rainy
all the time fall is like the bathroom
at a Taco Bell
salumi I feel wet for some reason I have
no idea what you can type it is and my
boots are stuck in something that looks
a little bit like swamp water but by all
means cream your jeans these you saw
orange leave that's why I said
everybody's like Oh fall you could cover
it up all you are but your pumpkin spice
latte and you're still in the bill the
Taco Bell bathroom no idea what you're
doing with your life
alright everybody thank you for watching
this week as always you can find her
videos every week on
whineaboutit.tumblr.com my page there's
facebook.com slash BuzzFeed man and you
find them on YouTube now a bust B video
you can look up whine about it off
BuzzFeed it'll be right there on YouTube
that's it that's everything
I always have a muffin it's my muffin